[Music]
the lights and the resorts are what
usually attract people to las vegas but
in and around the entertainment capital
there's a lot of art to be found
there really is just south of las vegas
is the seven magic mountains joe moeller
tells us why it has become the magical
place to visit
on your way in or out of las vegas
look how tall it is in the middle of the
empty desert south of las vegas
the yellow one you can find crowds
pulling off the busy interstate
snapping instagram worthy photos oh
that's so cute
these stacked colorful boulders draw
people away from the city
hop skip and jump away and we've never
been out here so something fun to do for
the family the art installation is
called the seven magic mountains
the totems are 30 to 35 feet tall it's
super cool and it's way bigger up close
than we can see it from the road we pass
by here all the time
a swiss artist initially wanted this to
be here for two years but because it was
so popular it stayed
this location has become a popular
social media photo destination
all over social media facebook instagram
all my friends came here melissa aller
has driven by several times
how about this these are not the typical
las vegas strip
photos many people say it is simply
something different that changes up
their trip to nevada
it's questionable if they glued that
thing there
hundreds of people come to this
attraction every single day
one of the best parts about it it's
completely free reporting near gene
nevada i'm john moehler
free is key the outdoor installation
remains open but they do ask
people to please practice social
distancing be smart wear a mask when you
go visit and take those photos